PROFESSOR: Today's lecture
continues the thing we're
doing with scattering states.
We send in a scattering state.
That is an energy eigenstate
that cannot be normalized
into a step barrier.
And we looked at
what could happen.
And we saw all kinds of
interesting things happening.
There was reflection
and transmission
when the energy was
higher than the barrier.
And there was just reflection
and a little exponential decay
in the forbidden region
if the energy was lower
than the energy of the barrier.
We also observed when we
did the packet analysis
that a wave packet
sent in would have
a delay in coming back out.
It doesn't come out immediately.
And that's the property
of those complex numbers
that entered into the
reflection coefficient.
Those complex
numbers were a phase
that had an energy dependence.
And by the time you're done with
analyzing how the wave packet
is moving, there was a delay.
So today we're going to
see another effect that
is sometimes called
resonant transmission.
And it's a rather famous.
Led to the so-called
Ramsauer-Townsend effect.
So we'll discuss that.
And then turn for the last
half an hour into the setup
where we can analyze more
general scattering problems.
So let's begin with this
Ramsauer-Townsend effect.
And Ramsauer Townsend effect.
Before discussing
phenomenologically
what was involved
in this effect,
let's do the mathematical
and physics analysis
of a [INAUDIBLE] problem
relevant to this effect.
And for that [INAUDIBLE] problem
we have the finite square well.
We've normalized
this square well.
Having width to a.
So it extends from minus a to a.
That's x equals 0.
And there's a number minus v0.
v0 we always define
it to be positive.
Therefore, v0 is the
depth of this potential.
And the question, is what
happens if you send in a wave?
So you're sending in a particle.
And you want to know
what will happen to it.
Will it get reflected?
Will it get transmitted?
What probabilities
for reflection, what
probabilities for transmission?
So of course, we would have to
send a wave packet to represent
the physical particle.
But we've learned that dealing
with energy eigenstates
teaches us the most
important part of the story.
If a particle has some
energy, well roughly,
it will tend to behave
the way an energy
eigenstate of that energy does,
as far as reflection and as far
as transmission is concerned.
So we'll set up a wave.
And there's a coefficient A.
So there's an Ae to the ikx.
That is our wave.
And it's moving to the right.
Because you remember
the time factor,
e to the minus iet over h bar.
And when you put
them together, you
see that it's
moving to the right.
But presumably, there
will be a reflection here.
The wave comes in, and
some gets reflected
and some gets transmitted.
And the part that gets
transmitted probably
will get partially reflected
back here and partially
transmitted forward.
But the part that is
partially reflected
will get again reflected here
and partially transmitted back.
It seems like a
never ending process
of which, if you think
physically what's happening,
there's a reflection
at the first barrier.
Now you say, wait a moment.
Why would there be a reflection?
Classically, there would
never be a reflection.
If the potential goes
down, the particle
would just be able to continue.
We had reflection
when we had a barrier.
Well in quantum mechanics,
any change in the potential
is bound to produce
a reflection.
So yes, if you have a
potential like this,
like a jumping board,
and you come in here,
there's a tiny
probability that you
will be reflected as you come
into this potential drop.
So OK, so this
will be reflection.
So at the end of the day,
there might be many bouncings.
If you imagine a
particle doing this.
Some probability of reflection,
some of transmission.
But the end of the day,
there will be some wave
moving to the left here.
So we'll represent it
by Be to the minus ikx.
So in this region,
we have A and a wave
with amplitude B going this way.
In the middle region,
the same will be true.
There will be some
wave going here,
and some wave that bounces
due to this reflection.
So there will be a--
I don't know what
letters I used.
I'd better keep the same.
C in this direction and
D in this direction.
And now I would
have Ce to the ikx.
Well, that e to the
ikx is not quite right.
Because k here, k squared
represents the energy.
k is the momentum and
k squared is energy.
So if you have an
energy eigenstate-- oh,
my picture is very crowded.
So I'll do it anyway.
A is here.
Maybe I'll put C and D here.
And now with A and B here I
can write this as the energy.
You have a particle with
some energy coming in.
And there is this wave
here and k squared.
It's 2mE over h squared.
E is positive scattering states.
And indeed, E from that equation
is h squared k squared over 2m.
What do you know?
But at this point,
the total energy,
kinetic energy of the
particle is bigger.
If e is replaced
by e plus v0, which
is the magnitude of this drop.
So here there will be a k2x
plus De to the minus ik2x.
And k2 refers because it's
region two, presumably.
People use that
name. k2 squared will
be 2me plus v0 over h squared.
And finally, to the right
of the potential square
well there will
be just one wave.
Because intuitively,
we should be
able to interpret
this as some wave that
goes through, but has nothing
to make it bounce or reflect.
So we try to get
the solution, which
will have just some wave
going in this direction.
And it's called Fe to the ikx.
And I can go back to
the label k because you
have the same energy
available as kinetic energy
you had to the left
of the barrier.
OK, so we've set up the problem.
The wave function I
would have to write it
as three expressions.
One for x less than a, one for
x in between a and minus a,
and one for x greater than a.
And those are this one,
two, and three formulas.
Any questions about
this setup so far?
OK.
Well, at this moment
you will eventually
have some practice on that.
The thing that you want to do is
relate the various coefficients
and define some reflection
and transmission coefficients.
We saw we had to think in
terms of probability current.
That's the better
way to get an idea
of what you should call
reflection or transmission
coefficient.
So we have to be careful with
the case of the step potential
when we compared the
meaning of the wave that
was moving to the right.
The amplitude divided
by the incoming wave
was not quite the
transmission coefficient.
But in this case,
the nice thing is
that the wave to the left
and the wave to the right
are experiencing
the same potential.
So they can be
compared directly.
So I will be able to conjecture,
it's reasonable to conjecture
that we can define
reflection and transmission
coefficients as follows.
We'll have a
reflection coefficient
should be B over A squared.
B represents a reflected
wave, A the incoming wave.
The transmission
coefficient you may guess
that it's F over A squared.
And this all will
make sense if we
have the reflection plus the
transmission is equal to 1.
So we have current
conservation, conservation.
And the current, which
is the net probability
flow to the left of the barrier
or the depression over here,
is J on the left is proportional
to A squared minus B squared.
You remember, we
computed it last time.
If you compute the probability
current to this Ae to the ikx
plus Be to the minus ikx,
you get two contributions.
Essentially A squared
minus B squared.
There's a factor of h
bar k over m in front.
At any rate, this should be
equal to the current that is
flowing out in this direction.
You see, whatever current
is coming in to the left
must be the current
going out to the right.
So this is f squared.
So current conservation
really tells you
that A squared minus B
squared is equal to F squared.
And if you pass the
B to the other side,
you get A squared equal
B squared plus F squared.
And dividing by
A squared you get
1 is equal to B over A
squared plus F over A squared.
And that's the reflection
plus the transmission
So the way we've defined
things makes sense.
Reflection and transmission
are properly defined.
And this is because current
conservation works well.
So reflection coefficient
is essentially
the flux in the reflected,
the probability current
or in the flux in the
reflected wave compared
to the flux in
the incoming wave.
The transmission is the
probability current or flux
of probability in the
transmitted wave compared
with the one incoming wave.
So you've done all
of this set up.
Now you can't avoid,
however, doing
a little bit of calculation,
which is boundary conditions.
You have one, two, three,
four, five variables.
And somehow, you want to
calculate these ratios.
So you have to say that the
wave function and the derivative
is continuous at this point.
And the wave function
and the derivative
is continuous and this point.
That would give you
four conditions.
And that's reasonable.
We have five variables.
But you know, the
overall normalization
could never be determined.
So things can be
determined in terms of A.
So you can expect that
with four equations
you can solve for B, C,
D, and F in terms of A.
But the overall scale of
this total wave function
is undetermined.
Its boundary conditions
will give you constraints,
but it will never
determine the magnitude,
the overall magnitude
of an energy eigenstate.